and The Wall Street Journal reports more
employers are looking to fill so-called
hybrid jobs those are positions that
require combination of creative and
technical skills 12 percent of all job
openings are for hybrid jobs that's
according to a study by the job market
analytics company burning glass
technologies jobs growth for the
positions is expected to be 21 percent
in the next 10 years more than double
the rate for jobs overall in our
work-in-progress series we've partnered
with LinkedIn to take a closer look at
issues affecting the workforce LinkedIn
editor-in-chief Dan Roth is here with a
look at what these new requirements mean
for job hunters great to have you back
example so if I'm interpreting what this
was well it's not just about mastering
technology it's about knowing how to
interpret it and utilize it right yeah
well it goes even beyond that it is you
know the hard skills get you in the door
and the soft skills keep you moving up
you have to know how to do jobs like a
you've got to understand cloud computing
if you want some of these jobs of the
future but just knowing how to do the
technical skills are not enough because
you have to keep building new skills we
know that by 2020 roughly one third of
the skills that employers are gonna
demand are ones that we don't even know
what they are yet so you can't just know
these certain skills and say alright I'm
set for life you have to know how to be
persuasive how to be adaptable how to
have great oral communication skills how
to write you have to be able to do all
the things that make us human and help
us to learn from each other examples of
specific yeah I want to know what is a
hybrid jet what is a hybrid job a hybrid
job would it's a great hybrid job sure
well being a cloud in cloud computing
the truth is almost all of these jobs
are hybrid jobs if you're doing anything
with AI or cloud computing that involve
more than just coming in and doing
programming you know baseline
programming you have to know how to be
able to manage large teams you have to
know how to manage other people you have
to be persuasive inside the office and
outside the office that's what we mean
when we talk about a hybrid job it's a
combination of soft skills and hard
skills
what can universities other vocational
skills do to help teach these so-called
soft skills for these hybrid jobs well I
think you've heard a lot about well you
need to move into stem you got to think
all only about tech the truth is you
have to have a combination of liberal
arts and of these tech skills you want
to be able to be good at science and at
everything that makes us really
to each other I think it goes well
beyond schools though it is on us to be
constantly working on our own skill
development it means taking courses it
means always learning it means watching
YouTube course is taking LinkedIn
learning but you have to cut you have to
invest in yourself this seems so much
akin to the debate about doctors medical
doctors not only having the skills
they're required from the science books
but also the bedside manner would that
be analogous yeah I think that is and it
goes I would say that the difference
though is that the human body is not
changing all that much when all of the
skills that we need no matter what
industry you're in or what you do you
have to know these skills so it's not
enough just to say well I've learned
what I've learned I finished school I've
studied in this one particular field all
these fields are converging and you have
to understand for instance cloud
computing no matter what you do you have
to know cloud computing data science the
most in-demand job is in demand across
every industry so as these industries
and this digitization pushes all these
companies together and we start
competing with each other in new ways
you have to know skills that once we
wouldn't have had to know and it just so
happens that these jobs tend to pay
better I do that well not only do they
pay better but they're also in demand by
more industries and they'll probably be
in demand for longer periods of time so
if you think about well look I want to
stay employed after 50 I want to stay
employed well into whatever you know
then the new era comes or if I want to
change industries having these kind of
skills make it so that you can be much
more flexible all right yeah thank you
good information thanks a lot good to
see